hello and welcome to digital spelling
Riley laughs Bella and I'm here to teach
at all tips and tricks that you need to
build your special brand and become a
digital spelling expert just to give you
a quick primer on my background I'm a
digital marketing consultant social
media expert professional speaker and
best-selling author I've grown my own
online business from scratch until it
was turning over five tickers a month
and now I'm here to help you do the same
whether you're looking to upsell to the
existing customer target a new business
or boost your webs traffic grow your own
social network or think you become a
better all-around digital speller I'm
here to make that happen
during this course you're going to gain
a deep insight into what it takes to
master the art of digital selling along
the way we're delving to social stone
branding buyer personas conversion
optimization and much more in short
you're going to learn everything you
need to close more by the time you've
completed this course you should be able
to develop digital selling credibility
conversion of the customer research and
develop buyer personas develop an
integrated digital selling strategy use
a variety of sales tools to generate a
nurturing means in other words you'll be
developing sort of practical skills that
will make you a highly effective digital
spinner
whatever your industry and whatever your
business model the skills you'll learn
as we go through the call will prove
invaluable when it comes to growing that
scaling your business whether you're
just getting started or have been
selling for years I'm going to help you
expand your skill set so that you can
become a more effective digital seller
every single day we're going to cover
seven topics pertaining to all aspects
of digital setting each of which will be
broken down into bite-sized chunks
there's going to be a lot of real-world
examples thrown in so that you can get a
feel of how all this knowledge applies
to every day life
follow the practical advice that you'll
be given in this haul complete the
quizzes at the end of each module and
use the slides and other course material
do all that and I can guarantee that
you'll be well on your way to becoming a
digital selling rockstar ninja guru or
whatever else you may care to call
yourself even if you have previous
experience in digital selling there
should be a lot here that's new to you
so whatever your background whether
you're just getting started or a sales
veteran I can promise there be modules
of this digital selling calls that will
be entirely new to you as the course
progresses we'll be diving deep into
areas that won't have encountered before
and certainly not in this sort of detail
[Music]